yes so this is the most interest bro I'm
so pumped you ask this question I'm glad
we're getting to say it here if you're
not great at it but you love it more
than life should you go after it the to
mean the answer is yes the problem is
please also recognize you're probably
not gonna get rich like if you love
basketball more than life it's just what
you've always loved you might just make
forty nine thousand dollars a year being
a basketball coach and having a lot of
time on your hand to play basketball
it's just you gotta understand you can't
have everything all the time always it's
just life I think happiness trumps
everything easy for me to say because it
really worked out for me because
happiness coincides with financial
upside I have friends who make seventy
four thousand dollars a year that are
just happier people than friends that
are making eighteen million a year that
are not you've got to do you but please
don't let the entrepreneurial society
don't let me don't let your parents push
you into what success is it's different
for all of us but and this is the big
but you got to be self-aware about it
you